spawn opening fruition nearly always
opens this way against the top players
in the world
we're going to see an open sicilian no
we see white's bishop come out and this
is something that the two players
debated earlier today
and uh okay slightly different take on
that previous game still a well-known
position white's light squad bishop
saving itself
and uh yeah black's knight coming out
that needs to get the king castled it's
all about fighting for the center for
russia is going to try and break out
magnus meanwhile just trying to stifle a
smile there
he's going to castle his king to safety
this is
magnus showing he means business he's
playing all his best openings
no more kind of freestyling no more
experimentation
and okay duder takes a bit of us uh
sorry not duda frugia takes a bit of a
slower approach
yeah i mean ferugia likes these kind of
setups doesn't he i mean he he's one of
their
leading players as we've mentioned
before under royal lopez the spanish
opening and i expect him now to start
shoving his knight over to the king's
side uh but magnus has a nice space hold
in the middle of the board so he only
needs that draw so he's just got to hold
the position a bit of a similar
structure to what he got in the last
game in some ways
can frugia break out here comes the
night and things heating up for well i
expect a very interesting middle game uh
fuse has got to bounce in the middle at
some point with a break
to liven it up
yeah and i think both sides are going to
be happy with how this opening has
panned out magnus you know he's got that
space advantage that he so loves on the
left
and he's actually keeping the position
relatively closed and there's so much
tension on the board so many
possibilities anything can happen
anything can happen for ruja meanwhile
redevelops that white light squared
bishop to a slightly better diagonal
staring down at the black king pinning a
pawn maybe the white bishop will go into
the center of the board we saw a very
similar pattern uh a few games ago
between these two
it's just very tense i think ferrous has
chosen a decent opening attempt just
keeping all the pieces on and
maintaining the tension just hoping that
magnus maybe gets impatient but magnus
in this scenario where he needs to draw
he's happy to trade off pieces
will those light-squared bishops
disappear
farouza one kind of good winning attempt
in these must-win situations is to
change the pawn structure he could trade
off these light squared bishops double
whites uh double the black pawns now
or will he just leave things as they are
the white rook on the open file on the a
file i quite like but
hard to achieve much with that
he just looks very relaxed the world
champion yeah
yeah he seems very relaxed in his
tournament in general i mean you know we
were talking about him laughing in the
first game
and he's just been really chilled in the
interviews as well which is great to see
we saw the bishop go here in that other
game didn't we quite fully enough but in
that game magnus was able to i think he
captured it with his knight
similar idea here yeah and magnus got
very nice game from from doing that and
uh
well he must be equal now he's got all
his pieces developed he's got a bit of a
space advantage
and um
not any problems for the world champion
here at the moment is uh white gonna do
anything with this excursion
on the a line
just looks like a one move threat
black's knight on that left side is
threatened
you can just defend it with a rook
uh you can make an argument for moving
it if you really need to
it is one open file but
if that's it that ferugia can kind of
claim as activity then it shouldn't be
enough
i wouldn't be surprised if the rook next
to magnus's king kind of swings across
it's actually very difficult to find a
plan for farouja because any pawn breaks
doesn't that really help his position
and uh yeah as you mentioned david it's
not it's not easy to kind of take
control of the a line and do something
with it
meanwhile magnus probably has a
relatively straightforward plan
and that is just to consolidate and then
maybe at the right time push forward
with uh f7f5
yes such that whatever
really i mean
i would have thought he could do a
similar plan we mentioned before take
the bishop move the knight back and and
throw the f pawn up the board no i mean
isn't that uh maybe if you just played
the ship if uh
if he wants to play for the win then
that's what he would do yeah and now i
needed a draw i'm surprised he's taking
risks yeah but now the f pawn at least
is ready i mean to go i mean yeah this
this this looks quite
quite normal i guess in some ways i mean
yeah but you'd be a bit scared about
this would you david just for changing
the structure look great now it's easier
for white to control the a file
i mean it's still there's nothing wrong
with it clearly for black uh objectively
it's just a matter of taste but it is
risky it's riskier than just kind of
sitting on the position and doing
nothing which magnus could have done
and lower on the clock forusia almost
one minute up
he needs to somehow get the white pieces
active as you mentioned black's pawns
are coming so you need to get those
white minor pieces rearranged at some
point yeah maybe the white queen could
swing across to the corner just to
completely dominate the a file so tense
yeah magnus is happy it is him against
the teenagers now and it is
magnus in the lead if he only gets a
draw in this game he will win the match
and it's uh
for prague as well to make a comeback
against duda but the bar actually right
now over to prank side in that game and
the bar now shifts side in this one i
was surprised by this move because i
thought ali reza's last move with the
queen actually prevented this pawn push
because now there's like maybe ideas of
playing bishop to spawn
and unleashing
some uh hidden attacks
yeah a lot of calculation to be done for
roger can he go for a direct tactic
and uh
maybe while he
thinks here while he calculates this
shall we okay we will see a move
from russia
okay this is odd we're looking at
ferrucci's screen right now looks like
he's clicked his rook in the middle of
the board
looks like he's about to swing it across
the whole way to the left maybe
trying to guess his move here he needs
to move quickly because he spent a lot
of time on this one move a minute now uh
almost for fruit and he's going to go
for the tactic you mentioned there
ivanka he does give up the white bishop
temporarily this bishop will be captured
otherwise magnus has just lost a ball
and then there will be a discovered
check
uh white's pawn in the middle okay
magnus did blunder this i think magnus
just took his eye off the ball for one
second
this is the type of thing i just i don't
know it feels like magnus is playing for
the win but he only needs the draw
taking risks
yeah well the position suddenly has
gotten a little bit wild
so many things to calculate
and uh
that white queen on the same diagonal is
the black king like
he i don't know he couldn't protect his
king in the corner that's what i would
have done
that black king now is vulnerable
yeah and the more tactical it gets
obviously the better chances white has i
mean uh yeah if it looks like you're
right david this this idea was a bit
risky i mean but the last move was
actually just a blunder i think and uh
uh magnus not not happy with the way
things are gone you don't wanna even if
black's okay here you don't wanna enter
into complications
um in these types of positions against
especially uh farouza so uh there's a
chance of a playoff coming up here maybe
and here we go tactics on the board
chaos not white is it one piece down he
did unleash this discover check with his
queen he just sacrificed a second piece
uh but now he wins the black rook and
what is the material count black has a
bishop and a knight for white's rook
there are pawns all over the place this
knight jump
suddenly a discovered attack black's
rook is hitting the white queen
queen can move though
a few choices of squares very strange
material imbalance here i mean uh fruit
has got to risk it and he's got to be
happy with uh sort of imbalanced
material because you need that when you
need to win i mean you could maybe even
swap the queens off here when you've got
a lot of pawns on the queen side but
don't underestimate black's pawns as
well and black's got the two minor
pieces against the rook which can
coordinate extremely well together so uh
what do you do with a queen here i i you
know
can you give the queen up somehow i
can't see how you can get the queen up i
think you just gotta
you know play it in front of the rook
here and do something like that maybe or
yeah maybe yeah step it next to the
black queen yeah offer a trade in that
way i mean it's so complicated
incredibly complex yeah i mean magnus
did he blunder this or did he calculate
it uh either way it seems to have worked
out just about all right for him
and uh ferruccio now under on the clock
but this is the most he could have asked
for ferruccia from the position he had
just chaos just tactics it's normally
suiting his style this type of thing
yeah this position is just insane
actually i'm not even sure who is better
to be honest
i mean
anything can happen the white pawns can
get motoring up the board the black
pieces could coordinate very well but
either way one thing for sure probably
white needs to trade off the queens
yeah yeah i mean black spawns in the
middle it can be very dangerous soon as
well so
you you know when when little things
like this happen tempo is so important
you don't want to lose tempo in these
little exchanges
if you can help it because every tempo
lost gives your opponent that chance to
gain the initiative um so i don't know
where the queen goes here is farouza
clicked on his rook at the bottom of the
board
uh you can see the piece that's
highlighted is his rook at the bottom
but his queen is attacked on the top
rank
so he can't move that piece why is he
clicked on it it's bizarre
unless there's some crazy tactic that i
don't see
what wow
i'm a bit worried else about his clock
time because he's ticked under 45
seconds no he needs to move that white
queen
nothing else to do he does finally
retreat his white queen
black bishop attacked
yeah he's just clicking on the rook
randomly yeah
it's a bit bizarre
yeah risking mouse slips there yeah
mouse looks horrible maybe this is a
good choice of square yeah the white
queen uh
yeah helping to protect the black pawn
next to her and what a mess this
position is now i mean uh there's a
material on balance and there goes
another pawn in the center um who who's
got the better
is the rook stronger than the knight and
bishop or the knight and bishop gonna
coordinate that pawn looks incredibly
strong as well god two squares from
queening uh these guys they they have
such fun games
i can see why
yeah i can see why magnus wanted to play
frozen in the world championships
because you can imagine the chaos that
would uh would erupt in those tactical
encounters commentating on that that
would be so funny that would be
brilliant under 20 sec 15 seconds
actually for ali reza faruja
you need to keep an eye on that
dangerous past porn that black has
and
gosh this position is so
crazy
it looks like white's now centralized
and white's maybe got the better control
here right i mean he's keeping an eye on
that black past pawn if that pawn goes
and surely white's better white's rooks
are
roaming free as well and black's minor
pieces they can't really move right you
can't move the bishop that much i don't
think i say that so
i'm not even sure you can't move the
night that well so i i think white is
now er the favorite in this one could be
going to the armageddon and look at that
o'clock time three seconds three seconds
wow i didn't see that
so
he did not lose on time for russia there
three seconds okay the queens are just
coming off there's a big threat of
checkmate if black's rook comes down to
the bottom of the board but no white
king now has breathing space
really nice move there from verusa
creating breathing space trying to
undermine the defender of the black
knight
i mean we know that frieza is so good
when he's got no time on the clock but
he's the only player i think you could
handle having no time the clock no one
else in the world could play this
position with seconds
on the clock especially not against
magnus so the material count right now
white has a rook
and two pawns for black's knight and
bishop so white has a small material
advantage the rook and two pawns worth
seven the night bishop worth six
but it's chaos and look at this from
magnus pushing pawns giving up more
pawns white now has three extra pawns
and uh okay where's this knight jumping
to some nasty nightfall threatened but i
i reckon that he's his whole idea with
pushing harry up the board is he wants
to set up a dangerous mating net he
wants to put that king under pressure
and suddenly you see
he's just up the pace
yeah and white's rook retreating the
blackrook is now going to try and get
active and uh i just like where the
knight and bishop are right now they're
great uh on great squares they can't be
kicked around but it's all about those
two white pawns
farouz is just running with them
sprinting with those two on the board
they might decide this game yeah yeah
has black got enough counter play uh
against white's king i don't think so
and here comes the b pawn barry is
coming barry is gonna queen himself
there's a night fork in the position but
that is easy to run away from uh black
tie if it centralizes it feels like
magnus was trying to hustle for asia on
the clock but ferugia survived and now
has nearly 20 seconds and and the plan
now for white is very simple you just
try to queen the pawn push that pawn get
a queen so magnus has got to go for
these tricks and such here um but i
don't know those pawns looking too good
now yeah barring a massive turnaround we
are heading for armageddon
in this clash look at the two white
rooks as well combining
barry the b pawn is just running how do
you stop it from watching up the board
you can't you have to try to set up some
counter-attack but that's
very difficult and so magnus is trying
so his idea is to relocate the bishop to
the d4 square so he can attack the pawn
but that is not going to
work it's not really going to work quite
rook retreating a bit of a mysterious
one there a bit of an odd choice of
square now black's bishop most likely oh
look at the bar yeah i think maybe that
was a mouth slip from ferruccia it would
have made sense to bring the white rook
to this square immediately he lost a
move there it could be it could be i
totally agree with you yeah he's lost a
very important tempo there because if
it's his move now he can move the other
pawn but can magnus create more problems
here i mean can he do something with the
knight now potentially the bishop and
brooke are very well placed uh start
attacking the knight here he comes with
the knight and the knight is now ready
to jump in maybe opening up the white
king a little bit more magnus is back in
the game yet again here that one little
mouse slip there that night now jumping
forwards looks like the natural move to
play
i mean it's so tense but okay he comes
another way
so surprising odd okay he's really going
for this white rook uh farouza sneaky
there lifts his rook to the top of the
board and oh this could
win a piece now for white both the black
knight and black bishop are attacked
magnus had to give up his bishop
now pawn's on the same side of the board
this should be a win for white his
ship's pawns are just too loose yeah and
you've got you've got two rooks here as
well haven't you two to annoy black's
position and
um
yeah this is this is simplifying
somewhat but
this has been up and down hasn't it i
mean armageddon looks so lightly now oh
brooks are off the board black needs a
miracle the black knight needs to find a
better square before it's too late
yeah this one should be a win for white
white's rocket is clearly better than
that black knight
still some hope because knights are very
crafty pieces and it can jump forward to
give a check
and that's what's happening is he just
lost his pawn yeah he hasn't
just leaned back and put his hand on his
head on he just lost a pawn for free
suddenly no more easy win this is a
fight
how he just gave away a pawn for free
walked into a check it was the clock i
think that played a big factor there
black's king will step back
white's remaining pawn is under fire as
well this one
this is so hard because the the night is
actually separated far away from the
king
this is a very nice move i mean you've
got to yeah like you say you think it
away the way you've got to try to win
this one is keep the black knight away
from the black king right but it gets
back
black knight is coming back it's going
to use its pawns to protect it and
suddenly who's playing for the win
only magnus if an eraser fruit doesn't
kind of pull the handbrake
uh magnus has chances
only i think that he's out of danger
there was a checkmate threat there
black's king as long as he doesn't walk
into a checkmating net he shouldn't lose
any more magnus
he just needs to get his knight back
into the game
still some chances for white though
because the the black knight is
sidetracked at this moment in time the
black king is also stuck on the back
rank so you you you can certainly push
for the win here uh if you can just get
that knight of course it's going to be
winning for white
but here it comes back towards king this
is what magnus needs to do and i think
he's going to do it if he gets the black
knight next to the black king it's a
pretty simple technical draw and i think
he's done that now he's got the black
knight next to the king there you go
this is a draw the king can just look
after the night now you can see he relax
their body language as well uh magnus is
obviously very confident in this
position um keep the knight near the
king the king can defend the night
you've got to watch out for obviously
the obvious blunders but
it's uh he's held it
remarkably the problem here the reason
white can't win is you can never get
your king opposite the black king
black's knight will always check your
way as soon as you go one way with the
white king the black king will go the
other way and yeah the black knight is
just a perfect defender look how it
blocks the checks stopping the white
king from moving and there we go it's a
draw and magnus takes today's match wow
what a fight between these two a
handshake and it's over minus takes the
two points